this is the setbacks just remember it's
only intended to be used for
aromatherapy first I find a pine cone
with a lot of sap on it I scoop the sap
off the scale of the pine cone and
scrape it into my glass jar I keep
scooping and scraping until my jar is
filled with sticky icky sap then I drill
a half inch hole into this stump that I
like to meditate at I take this glass
sculpture I got from a sculpture Store
and put it in the hole I take a big old
scoop of sap with the SAT backs and then
set it aside for later using my creme
brulee torch I heat up the glass
sculpture I ready the ax while the glass
cools and then dab the sap into the
middle of the glass sculpture I walked
the incense over my face and give thanks
I set the setbacks aside contemplate
life and prepare to repeat the process